but a couple months ago like one of our
neighbors found out that his wife was
cheating on him and so this year he
doesn't really have any decorations so
that's one
[Laughter]
[Music]
down can you guys do Christmas
decorations yep not this year I love
Christmas I love it too I like to go
visit the Christmas decoration places
you drive by them dude I help my 75 y-
old dad put up these lights and he gets
on this big ass ladder and he climbs up
and it makes me so nervous cuz it he
like kind of loses his balance sometimes
and then did your brother come over and
pants him no he doesn't dud I my dad
yeah I help my dad put up lights every
year and he always wants to be the one
to climb up the L why don't you do it
it's full 75 no you know what he tells
me he's like no no I could do it better
cuz cuz he could like nail it and do all
the but parents they want to do it
themselves like that's their Joy but he
can't make a single mistake at that age
yeah but that keeps it keeps him sharp
yo yeah yeah yeah dude that [__] is
scary though but I like helping because
you should ZIP timee to the ladder dude
I let my dad do his Pimon picking cuz
you know like he loves to you get
nervous right fell off the ladder he
broke his rib and he didn't even know
damn he's a gangster he went for weeks
and this fool Works in x-ray I'm like
why don't you check yourself dude my dad
fell off the ladder too same thing he
was gardening he's like I can't breathe
that same [__] happened to my dad dud
you got to let dads do it man yeah so
why'd you ask that
well it's like Nick said right like um
you're you're driving you like to go
driving by yeah the the Christmas
decoration I just took the the kids to
some Christmas lights a couple days ago
we drove around man [__] color blind
they can't even tell they can see blue
they can see blue they can't see [__]
hey guess what when they saw blue they
were [__] loveing they're just
different shades of brown lights to them
yeah but sometimes they need the variety
they don't get the variety at home did
they start barking at the Santa Claus
float like Inflatables yeah a little bit
but like chill so one one um one guy he
he decorates his lawn right and then
there's a car driving by to check out
his decorations and then they opened
fire on his Santa knew it it's Dy they
shot up the sa they opened fire on his
Santa cuz it was red you think that's
why oh maybe he was he was Santa blo
Santa blo Merry
Christmas so yeah guy guy named Donald
Nelson just finished putting up his
Christmas decorations he just finished
oh outside his family Home in Lexington
and then um and this is I believe in
Kentucky yes that's crazy man the sh in
the Santa Claus got shot up yeah he got
he just he spent $200 on his father
Christmas was it inflatable I knew it
dude it had might have been a rival uh
holiday like because I think some
communities they get [__] we do oh
they do beef compete the places that we
go to go see the uh Christmas lights
they go all out you could tell they're
you could tell which houses are
competing with each other oh like the
whole street is decked out oh bro it's
like like blocks shooting is overkill
for that no is it is it Ryan no it's
under it's underkill it's not enough so
in my neighborhood we have a a
competition every year same [__]
remember last year I won yeah like the
Christmas light oh yeah you did yeah so
this year like did you bring the heat I
brought the [__] heat I brought
the noise too like this year cuz to me
it's like it's all about like last year
I don't even think about last year it's
all about like if I do it again that's
huge and then if I three repeat it
that's a dinos yeah dude that's forever
you can't it can never take away from
every year do you go buy even more
decorations and you add it I try to get
one more do one more thing than last
year yeah just to cuz like if my
neighbors couldn't keep up with me last
year now I'm an extra step ahead of
those [__] I'll say it is it's
it's hard to stay on top yo what's the
new what's the newest LED technology in
Christmas lights did you get anything
crazy where it had like patterns and
[__] no cuz it was like [__] what looks
like [__] what did you get LED he's like
LED some people think that covering your
house in those [__] dots is
decorating your house by the way that's
not what you do on dude I wrap all we
have palm trees and stuff oh I like
those I like those yeah yeah I wrap all
of them how dude like no no no I don't I
don't mine aren't tall mine are like
babies oh yeah they're coming up so I
wrap them all and like I dude you ever
like grab a palm tree before on accident
it like stabbing your hands and [__] I
don't give a [__] my arms were all
[__] up I don't give a [__] it's all
about beating my [__] neighbors
especially my next door neighbor you
have reindeers and Santa Claus that kind
of I have a reindeer yeah my neighbor
has two reindeer this year so I was like
oh oh but you have an angel I don't have
an angel damn no you going get a baby
Jesus on there I have a [__] kitty
cat though I have a light up kitty cat
that's isn't that from Halloween though
no it's got a little ornament on it so
it's Christmas do you remember like back
back in the day there'll be certain
neighborhoods that go all out and every
single house does it and then people
would like go drive by and like check it
out and then you would just go from City
to City people still do that they do
they still do that I just did that I
just did that with his kids with I took
my kids bro there they have some houses
this one guy had a pro projection screen
and he was shooting elf He was elf was
playing but then get this there's a
little sinus is go to 88.9 so you go to
FM and you9
watch it bro and it's good [__] Hest
you got like a short wave like throwing
it out bro you're sitting in the [__]
car Watching Elf that's [__] cool you
know and then there was there's another
one where there was a light show and
then they they tell you to go to the
radio station and then the radio station
and the light show is all like it's all
matching it's like the B sick dude
that's just laser noises is Star Wars
you know what I want to try is that uh
drivethru light thing oh yeah that
experience yeah cuz I don't want to get
out bro you know what I mean walk around
I remember doing that as a kid though
going to neighborhoods and then we would
just walk around the neighborhood it's
real fun it's Reales we went to this one
neighborhood for uh Halloween and I
guess like yearly they all get together
and they have a plan the whole [__]
Community is probably like maybe like a
mile by a mile they caution tape it so I
think they let all the neighbors know
after 5 we don't want any [__] cars
on the streets cuz we want kids to be in
on the streets and everybody agree to
that agre to that so when we went there
um no [__] it looked like [__]
Coachella with kids like it was just
like a massive everyone's three
everyone's everyone's [__] 3et tall
and then they had [__] [__]
projecting and I'm like crazy can you
imagine the one the one guy that doesn't
agree and then when a car does pull
through like a [__] Postmates or
whatever like all the parents are like
dogging them and like get out of
here my get are here that's a strong
neighborhood man yeah I was like this is
f [__] crazy dude it gets competitive
everywhere cuz like in my neighborhood
like so I have a lot of competition
obviously and people are trying to come
up and get me and stuff but a couple
months ago like one of our neighbors
found out that his wife was cheating on
him and so this year he doesn't really
have any decorations so that's one
down Steve is like The Art of War oh my
divide and
conquer he plays a long game he got them
the Steve is planting evidence in emails
I don't know I don't know who told I
don't know who
told where's your Christmas cheer this
year Steve is like that guy on the Block
where he's happy cuz he's the only one
with decorations and no one else
participated Steve steps outside drinks
his coffee and he's
like win by forfeit a win is a win dude
seeing their dark house it makes me hard
and all the other Christmas
decorations cuz I know they're home too
I know they're home there's there's just
no cheer there's no cheer in there isn't
it funny how you find this out like the
older you become you're like the parents
now like with the neighborhood gossip
dude that's
so healthy competition dude unhealthy no
it's it's healthy it's it's fair game
baby it's fair game all fair yeah y we
had a the opposite thing happen in
Downey next to my parents house there
the the neighbor [__] decorates their
house like crazy now just out of nowhere
but the strange I swear I'm not making
this up cuz it's going to sound perfect
the [__] dad committed suicide oh W
after he did it my parents next door
neighbor wait so he decorated it like
crazy no no no my parents nextdoor
neighbor the father they were like a
thae family the dad committed suicide so
now it's just the so they're happy about
it now they have but now they decorate a
lot what the [__] maybe he was a real
Scrooge oh maybe yeah he's the dad they
didn't want to let anyone buy any lights
or whatever like y now we get to have
lights and he's like that's going to
increase our power we can no we're not
doing that it was too practical and she
goes son now that your daddy is gone we
can have fun yeah he was a real py
Scrooge crazy yeah isn't that sad kind
of happy but it ended up with bigger
Christmas Che we went to um I'd be like
how I can't beat these guys their Che
too strong how does he beat them is the
question someone needs to commit suicide
in this house I send him letters every
day tell him to kill him [__]
backfired
oh no it's a great you're the oh
no trying to ruin their Christmas does
your whole block get involved though
like everyone does the christm is are
there kids though like you know how like
some neighborhoods right like it becomes
like like a young 20s or like it becomes
like senior and it's kind of like a
collection of the same age group do you
have like families or like the lot of
families a lot of retirees I noticed
like a lot of family like family streets
have Christmas [__] going on mhm that
makes sense and a lot of like young
families though I just have cats dude
and I got my my house is lit yeah but
all of your neighbors do it they go in y
all go in the ones the ones that I we
see is uh either young families or old
families where their kids are like grown
and they moved out of state or whatever
so they're trying to build a gingerbread
house to be like come here children yeah
so they miss like the kids so they'll
have crazy Halloween or crazy Christmas
so like the uh kids can come by cuz they
got time to do it and [__] they got like
the bird feeders trying to bring the
birds come here or like the book club
yeah the book I told my neighbor I was
like I was like you know we because we
watch football together I was like we'll
do it together we'll do lights together
this year so we can help each other cuz
you got to be on the ladder and all this
kind of [__] and then um and then he was
going out of town I was like yeah we'll
do it when you get back and then when he
got back my house is
done loser another loser intimidation is
the greatest and then the other day I
pulled one of his lawn steaks from one
of his reindeer and and it blew over cuz
were having a windy day it blew right
the [__] over so I was like if the
judges were going by today yeah it's
over it's over it's
over